voir des enfants bon c'est
pas trop vous croyez qu'il est revenu
cornichons je ne vais pas nounours tu
devrais aller voir oui j veux mon le
cheval
hop hop hop
bonsoir la maisonnée comment ça va très
bien nous juliette a été très sage elle
a bien mangé et elle a joué sans faire
de bêtises
bravo et cornichons pas de nouvelles
rien il avait pourtant dès qu'ils
reviendraient
salut aux gens
j'arrive par la fenêtre à présent oui
j'ai trouvé des jeunes et puis les
ascenseurs
moi je ne pense à
vous soit ma petite juliette as tu ne la
manquait du co2 charge et cornichons
qu'est ce que t'as pas un panier plein
de baleine de toutes les couleurs pour
pas prenez mon
de la laine de mouton est super un
preneur je vais te montrer comme on
tricote suis voir là une maille à
l'endroit
et à l'envers
oh
[Musique]
c'était plus des paroles
on ne vous fâchez pas et ça c'est un arc
pour nicolas un arc avec des flèches et
oui pour tirer des flèches au nord c'est
formidable et l'enfant je vais vous
montrer comment on tire à la
silence nicolas s'il te plaît
regardez tout je vise une étoile et la
flèche elle va par année saw vi
[Musique]
alors
je voudrais dire deux mots à nounours
c'est pour toi
l'eau
dit monsieur nounours veuillez avoir
l'obligeance d'arrêter de lancer des
flèches sur mon nuage
laisser jouer ses enfants tranquilles et
venez me rejoindre au patron je suis
désolé je n'ai pas fait exprès
genre humain est ma plage gros malin tu
en fais pas nicolas je te ferai d'autres
demain les enfants je me sens en bonne
nuit
quand il tape bien cornichons veut nuit
les petits
mas pulu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu es content de toi tu
lance des flèches sur les nuages à
présent aux patrons gelé pour faire ses
preuves en route maladroit bonnut les
enfants fait pour
oh
[Musique]